Technology gives us the ability to
create relationships in the supply chain
relationships between producers and
consumers much more flexibly and
rapidly.
We're seeing it already in food
production,
in transport resources such as journeys
in cars and parking spaces.
Um,
and we're seeing it in the,
in the manufacturer of custom goods.
So the image on the bottom left is taken
from shapeways where you can three d
print pretty much anything that you like
and the cost of this technology is
coming down.
Um,
okay.
At the same time,
these marketplaces are transactional and
we've got interesting opportunities to
affect the rate of exchange used in
those transactions.
There's a,
an alternative currency that's been in
use in Switzerland for nearly a hundred
years now.
The where that starts to have
contributed to economic stability.
Though I suspect with someone from the
lse chairing the debate,
we may have a comment on that.
Um,
five towns of cities in the UK have
their own local currencies now with
similar intentions and they're
increasingly using advanced technology
to support those currencies such as the
droplet smartphone payment system that's
being created in,
in Birmingham.
These rates of exchange offers the
possibility to compare the complete cost
of goods and services,
the financial costs and their social and
environmental implications with dynamic
low,
highly localized value to the
participants.
What it's worth to me now to have this
service rather than what it might be
worth to me to have it in two weeks time
when I really need it.
Okay.
I think there's tremendous potential
here to produce new information based
marketplaces that could support more
sustainable city systems,
but if there such a good idea,
why don't we have them do ubiquitously
already.
Okay.
And that comes down to something that's
been mentioned by the other by the other
speakers were cities are making progress
on this agenda.
It's where the coordinating the use of
their public sector and private sector
assets towards a cocreated division
towards a common set of goals and
objectives.
But in order to win that level of
commitment,
you don't only need the buy in of the
leaders and managers of those resources.
You need the understanding of all of the
stakeholders that they are accountable
to their employees,
the electorate,
their shareholders.
To appeal to that tremendously broad set
of interests.
We need to,
I think,
to appeal to some common instincts
amongst us,
all a sense of narrative and our ability
to empathize rather than focus on the
financial efficiencies created by smart
infrastructures.
And if we do that,
we may not get very far because smart
ideas cut across silos.
So those who realize the benefits may
not be those who are asked to make the
investment in the first case.
And instead we should be concentrating
on the social and personal and community
value that can be created when people
can,
and I can afford to buy better food
where they could afford to heat their
homes properly in winter when they have
access to affordable transport to places
of employment.